un forcené menace de faire sauter le
dépôt d'explosifs dans lequel il est
retranché ce militaire est artificiers
il refuse son départ à la retraite il se
dit déterminé les communes avoisinantes
ont été évacués le gign tente de
négocier la tente se poursuit une
incroyable bévue des gendarmes de roissy
ont perdu lors d'un exercice de sécurité
la valise n'a passagers dans laquelle il
avait glissé des explosifs elle a été
embarquée mais pour quelle destination à
bord de quel avion mystère
les fous ils n'ont rien donné jusqu'à
présent les restos du coeur ont 20 ans
demain commence la campagne d'hiver avec
l'ouverture des centres de distribution
alimentaire en vingt ans la précarité a
progressé elle tous maintenant les
jeunes et femmes seules avec enfants le
vendée globe est le premier à bandeau le
français hervé laurent a été victime
d'une avarie pour lui c'est terminé la
déception bien sûr c'est la deuxième
fois qu'il participait à cette course
autour du monde à la voile sans escale
et sans assistance
et puis à quelques jours de l'ouverture
du viaduc de millau cette balade entre
ciel et terre un dimanche pas comme les
autres les promeneurs à pied ou à vélo
ont pris possession du site mais
monsieur bonsoir depuis 48 heures
maintenant à militaire est retranché
dans un dépôt d'explosifs de l'armée
dans une petite commune de la marne
un adjudant artificiers qui refuse sa
mise à la retraite
un homme fragile semble-t-il qui
menacent de faire tout sauter et qui
aurait le savoir faire pour mettre son
projet à exécution
soixante deux tonnes d'explosifs autour
de lui répartis dans un site où se
trouvent plusieurs entrepôts de stockage
gégène et sur place un immense périmètre
de sécurité protègent des communes
avoisinantes
reportage jacques cardoze versini
travers c'est ici à l'intérieur de ces
bâtiments que le sous-officier désespéré
est retranché depuis vendredi soir régis
letrouit 47 ans est affecté à ce dépôt
de munitions depuis 1999
vingt-quatre heures après la fin de son
travail samedi soir une patrouille
découvre les portes d'un bunker
anormalement ferme à l'intérieur
l'artificier fait savoir qu'il a piégé
63 tonnes d'explosifs ils menacent de
tout faire sauter
ses motivations une retraite qui
approche et qu'il n'accepte pas ce qu'on
peut comprendre de la motivation de
l'intéressé c'est une demande de
réhabilitation en quelque sorte à
l'égard de ce qu'il estime une injuste
appréciation de ces mairies de ses
services au sein de l'armée ce militaire
du 8e régiment de mourmelon fait passer
une lettre à la ministre de la défense
il ne veut pas partir à la retraite à
l'âge de 47 ans ce qui est pourtant la
règle pour un sous-officier ce matin la
zone est entièrement bouclé et évacué le
dépôt de munitions contient des armes
lourdes des mines antichars ceux qui
connaissent le militaires redoutent un
passage à l'acte
c'est un très bon professionnel par est
il un artificier vraiment au top et qui
est et qui assez nerveux comme un assez
nerveux donc assez instable comme un bon
artificiers plutôt pointilleux sur ses
états de service et les rapports de ses
supérieurs il a déjà eu un certain
nombre de problèmes de avec avec sa
hiérarchie qui était pas simplement des
problèmes uniquement professionnelle en
termes de compétences relationnelles
autres ce soir 70 gendarmes quadrillent
la zone des démineurs et le gign ont été
dépêchés sur les lieux
il s'agit de dénouer une crise insolite
et d'éviter un drame et nous vous
retrouvons jacques cardoze en direct de
connantray d'après aux informations
comment se déroulent les négociations
entre le gign et l'adjudant bien coûter
c'est là une information officielle qui
est tombé il ya maintenant moins d'une
heure un premier contact a pu être
établi avec ce forcené
le gign a pu rentrer en contact
téléphonique il ya moins d'une heure
avec ce militaire il a pu s'entretenir
avec le négociateur du gign mais aussi
avec des membres de sa famille cet homme
n'est pas marié il n'a pas d'enfant mais
il a pu s'entretenir avec un frère et
deux soeurs lesquels ont été rapatriés
par avion spécial cet après midi à
l'initiative du ggn mais quelle n'a pas
été la surprise du gign d'apprendre ce
matin que ce forcené n'avait prévu
aucune liaison téléphonique possible ni
par l'intermédiaire d'un portable ni par
l'intermédiaire du
ligne fixe ce que l'on sait c'est que ce
forcené en tous les cas a pu communiquer
par papier puisqu'il allait fait passer
un message sous une chose une porte sur
lequel il avait griffonné qu'il voulait
à tout prix rentrer en contact avec sa
hiérarchie militaire le gign en tous les
cas c'est ce que nous dit la préfecture
ce soir ne lancera pas d'assaut c'est
une information officielle
et puis de son côté le forcené a fait
savoir qu'ils ne lancent qu'il n'avait
pas lancé d'ultimatum avant de pouvoir
obtenir ceux qui le demandent depuis
maintenant vous le savez 48 heures merci
jacques cardoze depuis ce matin par
ordre de la préfecture les quelques 400
habitants des villages alentour ont été
évacuées dans le calme certains sont
hébergés dans le gymnase d'autres chez
des voisins
tous sont dans l'attentes mathias
signant sylvain doba le gymnase était
assez grand pour accueillir les 400
personnes évacuées ce matin mais rares
sont celles qui ont choisi cette
solution d'hébergement
parmi elles odette et denise 80 ans
ces deux dames ont pris le parti d'en
rire qu'est ce qu'on fait vous ne pouvez
pas rentrer dans votre ferme
alors vous voulez aller où moi je veux
bien passer la nuit là vient la belote
une partie de cartes pour oublier une
matinée bien mouvementée seul je lui ai
dit je dois défendre est ici
la plupart des personnes évacuées
dormiront chez leurs proches ce soir
lorsque l'on dit aux gens qu'il faut
qu'ils évacuent bon il accède vers long
thier on leur dit que l'on va les
héberger provisoirement dans une salle
de sport même si à des aménagements ont
ils trouvent que très certainement les
amis ou la famille
ça sera plus conviviale après avoir été
recensés au gymnase ce couple de
retraités partis goûter la convivialité
chez leur petite fille de leur maison
qu'ils ont quitté à regret jacqueline et
martial marguet avait vu sur le dépôt de
munitions pourquoi vous vouliez pas
partir parce que j'ai dû moi je vais
fermer les volets pis c'est tout parce
que niveau carreau en décembre je mets
carouge m'en fous faut pas lire il avait
peur les gendarmes qui se fait quelque
chose parce que je savais que c'était de
ce soir le périmètre de sécurité empêche
toujours les 400 personnes évacuées de
rentrer chez elle l'afer est à peine
croyable et pourtant les gendarmes de
roissy lors d'un exercice de sécurité
ont placé une barre d'explosifs sans
détonateur heureusement dans la valise
d'un passager pour tester l'aptitude des
chiens détecteurs la valise a échappé à
leur contrôle et l'explosif avec placé
sur le tapis roulant elle a continué sa
route pour être embarqué dans l'un des
multiples avion qui était en partance
depuis aucune trace et des fouilles
systématiques dans les arrêts dans les
aéroports internationaux
une sérieuse bévue qui pourrait être
sanctionné fanni au vernet mathieu
bertal c'est un exercice comme celui ci
qui a mal tourné vendredi dernier à
roissy des gendarmes cachent des
explosifs dans la valise d'un passager
c'est un entraînement légal de la
brigade cynophile de l'aéroport aussitôt
le chien détecte la bonne valise
contenant le pain de plastic 250 g les
gendarmes félicite l'animal mais oublie
de récupérer le bagage qui part sur le
tapis roulant bien évidemment
immédiatement les gendarmes ont
déclenché des recherches
mais il y avait quand même pas mal de
chariots à bagages avaient vu en
partance et il nous a pas été permis de
les utiliser immédiatement
c'est une erreur d'inattention qui qui
parce que ça concerne les avions une
erreur d'inattention et qui a une
répercussion
nationale et internationale 90 avions
dans le monde entier sont susceptibles
d'avoir transporté cette valise toujours
introuvable cette nuit dès son
atterrissage le vol paris los angeles a
été méticuleusement fouillé en vain
certains passagers étaient inquiets que
va-t-il se passer s'il ya une étincelle
et si quelqu'un trouve l'explosif et
l'utilisent dans un autre but
c'est terrible les autorités françaises
précise que l'explosif est inoffensif
qu'il ne réagit ni aux chocs ni au feu
et qu'aucun détonateur ni et religieux
ce soir tous les exercices de ce style
sont suspendus et les deux gendarmes
auteur de cette bévue pourrait être
sanctionné petit tremblement de terre la
nuit dernière dans le nord-est de la
france un séisme de 4 9 sur l'échelle de
richter
c'est surtout dans le sud de l'alsace
que la secousse a été ressentie n'y a ni
dégât ni victime mais une certaine
attitude comme en témoignent ces
quelques centaines d'appels reçus par
les pompiers dans les départements du
bas-rhin dans les vosges
un tremblement de terre dont l'épicentre
était situé en allemagne david bouyre et
kristin dos quelques gravats et une
longue fissure dans un mur ce sont les
seuls dégâts visibles dans le village de
waldkirch c'est ici à quelques
kilomètres de fribourg que la terre a
tremblé cette nuit une secousse de 4
degrés 9 sur l'échelle ouverte de
richter
la secousse a duré dix secondes
nous avons ensuite reçu des appels de
gens inquiets et près de 120 au total
com le séisme a été ressenti en alsace
en bavière et jusqu'en suisse à colmar
la plupart des habitants ont été
réveillés en pleine nuit à 3 heures du
matin ça c'est impressionnant
le bruit
on sent quand même pas mal remuer dans
la maison obligé de cliquer
on attendait que ça se passe ça fait
peur quand c'est impressionnant reste
est moins fort que le président la
secousse telle qu'elle a été
enregistrées par les capteurs de
l'observatoire des sciences de la terre
à strasbourg le feu sérénon est une
région sismique connue
le tremblement de terre de cette nuit
était relativement violent mais par
chance il n'a fait aucun dégât
ce qui est important c'est surtout la
localisation du tremblement terre par
rapport aux zones urbanisées en
l'occurrence ici il est comme localiser
relativement loin ce qui explique
probablement le fait qu'il n'y a
aujourd'hui pas de dégâts en tout cas
déclarés
c'est le troisième séisme dans la région
en deux ans pas de quoi inquiéter les
spécialistes
ces secousses n'ont en fait rien
d'exceptionnel les restos du coeur ont
20 ans il ouvre demain comme chaque
hiver ce sens les centres de
distribution alimentaire qui vont à
nouveau fonctionner alors que la plupart
des antennes des restos du coeur offre
maintenant pratiquement toute l'année
des repas chauds à l'origine destiné aux
sans logis ce sont désormais les jeunes
les femmes seules avec enfants les
chômeurs en fin de droits qui arrivent à
se nourrir grâce aux restos du coeur et
angie qu'elle régit ce matin
ça va faire 20 ans que cette
chansonnette nous hante des 10 millions
de repas de 85 les restos du coeur sont
passés à près de 60 millions l'année
dernière
aujourd'hui nous avons sauté de volaille
tonnes de terre demi-lune cinq sites
répartis sur paris plus deux
camionnettes mobile ici les bénévoles
préparent deux mille cinq cents repas
335 jours par an
mais pas seulement des bénévoles pour
vous c'est important d'être ici est
important de travailler dans la vie ça
n'a pas de travail n'ont pu rien moi je
vais très vite les fondateur des restos
au compris qu'il fallait faire sortir
les bénéficiaires de l'exclusion en les
aidant à se réinsérer par le travail
les gens qui arrivent ici ont des
difficultés sociales très importantes en
particulier le logement et ne serait-ce
que trouver un logement ont récupéré ses
enfants pour des femmes qui ont vu leurs
enfants enlevés en mai dans des pays
étrangers il ya toutes sortes de
difficultés qu'on nous contribuer à
régler avec ici et qui font qu à leur
sortie en général ils sont quand même un
peu mieux dans une situation un peu
meilleure que celle qu'il avait en
arrivant ce soir grâce aux restos du
coeur et à vos dons des hommes auront le
ventre plein et se sentiront peut-être
un peu moins seuls et ça fait vingt ans
que ça dure
la grogne des médecins spécialistes des
médecins libéraux qui ont décidé un exil
de symbolique de 3 jours à barcelone
pour marquer leur mécontentement
une démarche délibérément provocatrice
que devrait suivre un millier de
praticiens qui fermeront leur cabinet à
partir de demain
ces exilés d'un moment refuse le blocage
des honoraires nathalie sapina mamady
diawara les dernières pancartes sont
arrivés et des ben ali
ce sont elles qui seront brandis demain
à tous par des médecins spécialistes
exaspéré par le gel de leurs honoraires
et très inquiets des réformes l'encours
de l'assurance maladie
il va y avoir un contrôle accru des
caisses par le biais de l'informatique
par le biais du dossier médical partagé
c'est à dire un flicage des médecins
depuis dix ans les tarifs des médecins
spécialistes sont bloqués 23 euros la
consultation pour un ophtalmo ou un
gynéco ici le docteur tritsch facture 10
euros de plus à ses patients illégal
mais indispensable selon lui pendant ces
dix ans il a fallu investir dans
différents appareils pour pratiquement
100 mille euros
et pourtant le tarif d'un civil social
n'a pas augmenté depuis maintenant 10
ans et c'est ce blocage qui pousse les
jusqu'au boutistes à une action
symbolique un exil de trois jours à
barcelone cette semaine pour y tenir un
congrès si nous optons perron et
acceptons ces tarifs économiquement
irréaliste
nous ferons médecine médiocre mais pour
l'instant pas question pour le ministre
de la santé d'intervenir
d'autant que des négociations sont
actuellement en cours
la caisse nationale d'assurance-maladie
travaille avec des syndicats de médecins
je les laisse travailler ils sont en
train de parler moi je crois au dialogue
social donc c'est entre l'assurance
maladie et les médecins que ça se passe
il faut commencer à devenir aussi un peu
responsables la coordination qui appelle
à l'exil en espagne et à la fermeture
des cabinets cette semaine représente
5000 spécialistes libéraux sur les 53000
qui exercent en france
les verts ont retrouvé leur tempérament
après l'unité exceptionnel d'hier sur la
synthèse politique des différents
courants aujourd'hui rien ne va plus
réunies en congrès ne sont pas arrivés à
élire leur nouvelle direction rendez
vous en janvier prochain et les nuques
vincent ferreira et la motion de
synthèse recueilli 4 179 voix 91,76 %
les airs tout sourire
c'était hier la quasi unanimité sur les
orientations politiques
ce matin les visages sont plus crispés
les portes se ferment les verts essaie
de se répartir les postes à la direction
et chacun veut sa part du gâteau à sa
cause est toujours d'actualité
maintenant comment ça va faire vivre un
peu de vie difficiles malgré trois tours
de scrutin
les verts ne parviennent pas à se mettre
d'accord sur un nouveau secrétaire
national
l'ancien ministre guy hascoët est
éliminée dès le premier tour
mireille ferri la protégée de dominique
voynet au deuxième
sergio coronado la valeur montante
disparaît au troisième il ya toujours un
moment de crispation dans un dans un
congrès est très souvent le moment de
crispation se pose quand on en arrive
aux questions de personnes ce qui s'est
passé hier est excellent ce qu'on fait
aujourd'hui
c'est la bouillie verte habituel des
habitudes que les militants de plus en
plus de mal à comprendre
on fait tout pour qu'une synthèse
hakkari tout a été fait regardons les
cocons aprilia et au dernier moment il
ya peu fou et
scandaleux qui arrive quand on est dans
le petite commune conduit aux gens qui
ont voté vous une fois n'est pas coutume
au congrès de reims pour la première
fois hier les verts ont réussi à se
rassembler une journée en tout et pour
tout dès aujourd'hui ils ont renoué avec
laurier tradition celle des querelles de
personnes c'était le 14 juillet 2002 un
homme muni d'un fusil a tenté de tirer
sur jacques chirac maxime brunerie
comparaît à partir de demain devant la
cour d'assises de paris après plusieurs
expertises psychiatriques
contradictoires il a finalement été
reconnu à peut-être jugé maxime brunerie
a milité pendant de longues années dans
un mouvement d'extrême droite
même si le mobile politique semble
écarter ce procès mettra en lumière ces
groupuscules radicaux jean marie née 14
juillet 2002 le président ne s'est rendu
compte de rien à 25 mètres de lui
pourtant un homme à épauler une carabine
et tiré une fois avant d'être maîtrisé
maxime brunerie 25 ans est membre d'un
groupuscule d'extrême-droite unité
radicale dont la plupart des membres ont
appartenu au front national et waimes
nerfs pour ce parti maxime brunerie sera
candidat aux municipales de 2001 à paris
quelques heures avant son acte il
annonce à des amis incrédule son
intention de tuer jacques chirac qui
n'aurait pas supporté dit il
la défaite électorale de l'extrême
droite ça peut effectivement déclenché
dans un certain nombre
deux cerveaux faible chez les gens un
petit peu un petit peu troublé une
volonté de passer à autre chose et
notamment de résoudre le problème de la
conquête du pouvoir par l'action le site
internet d'unité radicale condamne
l'attentât mais soutient le militant le
groupuscule et le site sont interdits
mais dans une interview téléphonique le
jour même de la dissolution l'un des
dirigeants guillaume lite annonce la
suite à monter une structure légale
il faut accepter par le système dans
fait dans ses statuts mais qui nous
permettent évidemment de continuer
exactement le même combat que celui que
nous menions auparavant voici la
nouvelle mouture d'unité radicale le
bloc identitaire toujours l'obsession
raciale et surtout les mêmes dirigeants
pour la ligue des droits de l'homme la
dissolution n'a rien changé
alors bien entendu c'est interdit de le
reconstituer sur reconstitution que
poursuivre des membres qu'ils
reconstituent mais on fait ça sous
d'autres formes et en définitive la
dissolution de la grippe elle a une
valeur symbolique
quand il s'agit surtout de compas
formelle comme celui-là unité radicale
ne comptait pas plus de 200 militants à
la prison de la santé le détenu brunerie
a pris ses distances avec eux soigné
depuis l'attentât en unité psychiatrique
mais reconnu responsable de ses actes
par un collège de psychiatres
l'homme qui a tiré sur le président va
quand même plaidé la folie
il risque la perpétuité une semaine
après la mort d'un jeune sur les champs
elysées lors d'affrontements entre deux
bandes de banlieue rassemblement dans le
calme ce matin en hommage à la victime
sa famille ses amis ainsi que les
habitants nuit commune des yvelines ont
participé à la cérémonie
en ukraine le leader de l'opposition
seraient en danger viktor iouchtchenko
affirme avoir reçu des menaces de mort
il aurait déjà été victime d'une
tentative d'empoisonnement pour preuve
la déformation de son visage celui qui
conduit la révolution orange se
présentera au troisième tour du scrutin
le 26 26 décembre prochain sous haute
sécurité
gilles rabin
avant iouchtchenko passait pour être le
playboy de la politique ukrainienne et
il plaît beaucoup aux électrices quel
que soit leur âge son vrai visage le
voici avant la tentative
d'empoisonnement de septembre dernier et
voici son visage aujourd'hui gros plan
sur les séquelles de ce qui était selon
lui une tentative d'assassinât ratée
avant ils vivaient la vie d'un homme
normal il lui arrivait parfois d'aller
en boîte de nuit
même si à sa façon de danser en
comprendre ça n'arrive pas souvent
aujourd'hui certes il est sauvé mais sa
vie est celle d'un homme blessé il
souffre autant que trois mois après
l'empoisonnement il est encore sous
morphine
le chef de l'opposition est toujours un
homme en danger et sa famille aussi sa
deuxième épouse et ses cinq enfants
l'accompagnent partout et la nuit il se
cache dans une datcha protéger la
banlieue de pia car iouchtchenko
continue de recevoir des menaces de mort
tous les jours il est persuadé qu'on va
de nouveau tenter de l'éliminer
physiquement
qui a osé yann ashton suis convaincu que
cushman le président sortant ne quittera
pas le pouvoir sereinement ni de façon
civilisée de la zone après des tests
dans cette église orthodoxe de kiev ont
prié cet après midi pour le salut du
chef de l'opposition
parce que son visage est celui du martyr
de la victime du résistant dieu et pour
la révolution orange cardio veut le bien
du peuple
d'après les médecins iouchtchenko
devrait guérir un jour ce que souhaite
c'est l'ukraine qui s'élevaient depuis
deux semaines et qui voudraient avec lui
retrouvé son vrai visage
au proche orient un signe de coopération
renforcée entre jérusalem et le caire à
travers cet échange de détenus la
libération d'un israélien condamnés pour
espionnage pour espionnage par les
autorités égyptiennes contre celle de
six étudiants égyptiens un nouveau signe
de détente au moment où devrait se
mettre en oeuvre le plan de retrait de
la bande de gaza en france le sujet
n'est plus tabou il est nécessaire d'en
parler le nombre de suicides augmentent
douze mille personnes chaque année se
donne la mort deux fois plus que pour
les accidentés de la route un colloque
se tenait ces derniers jours à toulouse
avec pour objectif de venir en aide à
ces familles qui ont tant de mal à
admettre un travail de deuil qui prendra
plusieurs années
muriel la saga de l'île bresse à 34 ans
cet ingénieur du cnes s'est pendu en
juillet dernier sa mère ne comprend rien
et cache toute sa souffrance
mais elle sait qu'elle est détruite on
peut exploser
on peut rien faire envoyer à l'extérieur
de ce qu on souffre on peut pas c'est
c'est quelque chose qui vous qui vont
droit complètement qui épie s'est
froissé noir c'est celle et enel on se
dit pourquoi il a fait ça qu'est-ce-qui
qu'est-ce-qui qu'est ce qui lui a pris
pourquoi quelles souffrances qu est ce
que je n'ai pas vu
maïté et tous les autres trouveront ils
un jour des réponses ou accepté pourquoi
il pas de réponse alors c'est sûr qu'il
y avait la période outils chez tous raté
j'ai tout raté
et quand on dit tu a élevé trois enfants
je dis non dit me dites pas ça me dit
pas ça c'est pas ce sentiment parce
qu'elle avait des enfants c'est y
arriver madeleine a perdu son fils de 17
ans une mort violente pour un enfant do
madeleine elle a choisi de se faire
aider pour commencer ce chemin de
douleur de deuil dans cette association
elle a trouvé une écoute quelqu'un qui
la laisse pleurer ça ahurissant c'est un
paradoxe énorme de loin des parents qui
ont perdu un enfant depuis 2 - 3 - 4
mois sans temps de dire à droite et à
gauche mais se côtoient sans arrête d'en
parler et c'est ce qu'ils entendent
et puis bien sûr il n'y arrive pas et il
s'est dit messier parce que je suis pas
bien je fous on est pas du tout là pour
éviter la souffrance ce que le deuil
c'est vraiment traversé une souffrance
mais avec des points de repère lors
expliquer qu aura des hauts et des bas
repérez cesser ses émotions et en fait
quand on sait de quoi est fait sa
souffrance elle est beaucoup moins
angoissante
on peut dès lors accepter de vivre avec
l'inacceptable survivre malgré la mort
nous évoquant un régulièrement dans nos
journaux la dangerosité de ces
chauffards de la route ces conducteurs
qui roulent sans permis et qui seraient
plus nombreux qu'auparavant naples
occasion d entendre
francis mazier bernard bonnes armes ont
rencontré en gérant de l'un de ces
automobilistes qui a roulé pendant 37
ans sans permis de conduire il le ferait
encore s'il n'avait pas été arrêté par
les gendarmes la voiture de cet homme de
58 ans immobilisé pour la première fois
un contrôle d'alcoolémie positif en juin
dernier
voilà ce qu'a mis fin à 37 ans de
conduite sans permis une très longue
période
hors la loi qui là dessus j'adore
conduire
c'est incroyable j'adore ça alors que
jusqu'à présent jamais d'accident aérien
ma femme elle est pensée elle quand vous
voyez des appels de phares en phase
informatique mans
le pied sur le plancher est à toi je
passais sens que je passe il la chantera
dans ça ne rentrait pas et si bien
passer le permis il a bien tenté de
l'obtenir d'abord à l'armée puis dans le
civil
deux échecs l'ont découragé de passer
l'examen
mais pas de prendre le volant moi je
n'ai que le permis pour moi c'est pas
une connerie 9 est mort c'est peut-être
ma médiation
quand on voit des jeunes qui vont les
stocks aussi voilà nous inventions gour
moi par exemple je suis d'accord je me
suis jamais perdu et pour l'instant
points en octobre dernier ce conducteur
son permis a été condamné à trois mois
de prison avec sursis par le tribunal de
bordeaux une peine dissuasive qui lui a
semble-t-il servi de leçon quitte à
faire n'importe quoi mais je réponds
présent et a même fait la voiture
ça m'est égal mais je veux plus voir
sortir si par exemple on suppose en
mettre un genre pour la voiture a fait
rater plus loin des jeux majeurs
j'aurais pu la mise en jeu m'avait ou en
prison
passer le permis aujourd'hui cet homme
surendettés dit ne pas en avoir les
moyens
ils s'accommodent donc de sa nouvelle
condition de simple piéton chapitre
financier le succès de l'assurance vie
qui est devenu l'un des placements
préférés des français au moment où la
bourse inquiéter petits actionnaires une
clientèle y compris de jeunes ménages
s'oriente vers l'assurance vie elle à
palau à la location
c'est fait le contrat et signe comme
plus de 22 millions de français
dominique chrome est désormais détenteur
d'une assurance vie
après un an de réflexion ce placement
emporté ses faveurs pour une raison très
simple nous par tous les jours de
retraite
qui fond comme neige au soleil sont
obligés de trouver les solutions et
cette solution plus intéressante
pourtant ce placement n'est pas
directement destiné à financer les
retraites mais il séduit depuis dix ans
le montant total des placements dans
l'assurance vie n'a cessé d'augmenter
jusqu'à atteindre cette année plus de
800 milliards d'euros à l'origine de ce
succès deux principaux avantages tout
d'abord au bout de huit ans les gains
sont exonérés d'impôts deuxièmement en
cas de décès le capital est transmis aux
héritiers en grande partie sans droits
de succession mais il y a bien sûr
certains inconvénients fiscalité et en
intéressante si on n'attend pas le délai
de huit ans qui permet de la rendre
intéressante on perd ce bénéfice fiscal
non imposition des plus values générées
brigitte de jarnieu elle a souscrit son
contrat il ya 16 ans aujourd'hui elle
utilise comme une véritable source de
revenus complémentaires actuellement
lusage que j'en fais c'est de pouvoir
quand j'ai besoin à les prélever un peu
d'argent selon les aléas de la vie
quotidienne soit effectivement des
à-coups pour des impôts pour des voyages
soit surtout essentiellement les études
de mes enfants
malgré tout depuis trois mois les
français négligent quelques peu
l'assurance vie parallèlement ils ont
trouvé un million de plans d'épargné
retraite populaire les pertes depuis le
mois de mai mais il est encore beaucoup
trop tôt pour parler de concurrence
signe des temps les compagnons du devoir
l'une des dernières institutions fermées
aux femmes changent de politique
cet ordre vieux de six siècles décidé
d'admettre en son sein des femmes
méritantes
trois d'entre elles hier ont été
adoptées dans cette charpentier ont
rencontré françois jenny un pied noir et
10 aux messieurs
charpentier et non charpentières elle y
tient jocelyne trente ans de métier et
30 ans d'attentats la porte du
compagnonnage
car jocelyne est une femme je ne
comprenais pas pour quelle raison un
garçon qui était plus mauvais qu mois
qu'on gardait qu'on l'adapté et que moi
et en filles ont refusé j'en ai souffert
une entourage à l'apathie jamais détesté
d'être une fille jocelyne c'est alors
façonner la carapace du charpentier à
chouiner les cours du soir puis son
propre tour de france elle est
aujourd'hui chef d'entreprise est la
première femme compagnons du devoir
après six ans de tradition masculine
pour moi c'est un bon coup d'oxygène
c'est déjà pas mal mais c'est un peu une
révolution dans les esprits il va de soi
que beaucoup d'hommes avaient tellement
l'habitude les trois hommes sur les
chantiers dans les ateliers que
l'arrivée des femmes était un peu
dérangeante pour certains quand on aime
ce qu'on fait je préfère faire sa quête
coudre un bouton
c'est bien plus pénible pour moi rouleau
le jeune homme
quand même à oui ça y est au boulot
et c'est le grand jour l'adoption comme
on dit jocelyne est un peu perdu au
milieu de tous ces hommes
pensez vous pouvez ne pas être adoptées
vont pas me faire ce coup là jocelyne
met fin à six siècles de masculinité
mais pas au mystère qui plane autour des
compagnons quoi le début donc filmé pas
interdit de filmer la cérémonie est
secrète profond de cette cave
jocelyne a bien été adoptée par ces
nouveaux frères elle est désormais un ou
une compagne ont quelques jours de
l'ouverture du viaduc de millau ce son
et les promeneurs marathonien aux
cyclistes qui ont pris possession des
lieux pour la première et dernière fois
une balade entre ciel et terre les eaux
lamberton parce qu'elles poussent ils
sont les premiers à se lancer à l'assaut
du plus haut viaduc du monde
certes ils n'ont pu traverser qu'une
toute petite partie du viaduc de millau
200 mètres à peine
mais c'est déjà un privilège pour une
fois c'est formidable on est les
premiers et dans 20 ans 30 ans reviendra
et on aura le souvenir de 2,2 ce jour
c'est super ça bouge pas assez bon ils
sont plus de vingt mille à avoir
participé aujourd'hui à un événement
exceptionnel
la balade des trois viaducs à pied en
roller ou à vélo une course de 30 km sur
l'autoroute a75 qui se termine au viaduc
de millau
les participants viennent de toute la
france mais ils ne sont pas là pour
l'exploit sportif je m'arrête on prend
des photos parce que c'est vraiment
magnifique c'est vraiment une super
journée de voir tout ce monde là chacun
qui découvre le viaduc à sa façon la
balade a été organisée par la direction
de l'équipement de l'aveyron une
tradition chaque fois que se termine un
grand chantier c'est un petit peu comme
à sculpteur qui a fini son oeuvre qui
veut partager ce bonheur là et puis qui
permet aux autres de venir toucher les
cobras apprécié l'insertion dans le
paysage la beauté mais la découverte du
viaduc n'est pas réservé qu'aux sportifs
toute la journée des curieux ont pu
faire quelques pas sur ce pont long de
deux kilomètres et demi
perché à 270 mètres au dessus du tarn
alors madame oui mais là comment le
trouver très bon monsieur vous avez un
très beau je suis très contente parce
que je ne pensais pas le voir terminer
je me suis dit je suis trop vieille je
le verrais pas je sais pas moi j'en sais
pas trop regarder à l'extérieur parce
que j'aimerais ça que j'ai le vertige
mais autres maintenant c'est formidable
à partir de ce soir plus personne ne
pourra marcher sur le viaduc de millau
les premières voitures sont attendus le
16 décembre premier drame de la saison
de ski dans les pyrénées-orientales un
skieur est mort lors d'une collision
avec un surfeur un accident qui nous
donne l'occasion de rappeler
l'importance de respecter les règles de
sécurité sur les pistes et anouk burel
délits de presse c'est une piste verte
dans une station de ski des pyrénées une
piste de débutants
rien de plus simple rien de plus sur a
priori c'est là pourtant qu'a eu lieu
l'accident
la piste est pratiquement en plate ce
n'était pas l'endroit on pourrait
s'imaginer qu'ils auraient ce type 2
deux collisions qui amènerait la mort
d'une personne il est midi passé hier
lorsqu'un skieur confirmé des 107 piste
sur le côté un surfeur à l'arrêt ils ne
se voient pas le choc est violent
la collision mortelle pour le skieur le
serveur lui s'en sort indemne
est ce que c'est la vitesse excessive du
skieur qui a provoqué la violence du
choc
a priori non on a fait un appel à témoin
pour avoir pour essayer d'avoir quelques
retours là dessus mais bon les on a
toujours pas eu de plus amples
renseignements pour le moment donc on va
éviter d'émettre une quelconque
hypothèse par rapport à la vitesse
l'accident est rare mais rappelle
combien la vigilance sur les pistes est
nécessaire chaque skieur s'offrant
surfeurs se doit d'être responsable
c'est comme quand on est sur la route il
faut faire attention il ya un certain
nombre de règles qu'il faut qu'il faut
et ses thoniers au niveau de la du
respect d'autrui
au niveau de la vigilance au niveau des
croisements de suite surtout plus
important c'est de respecter la
trajectoire du disquaire parole
christian amende entre contrôler sa
trajectoire est respecté à travers de
celui qui est en hausse lui cette
intervention ont eu lieu aujourd'hui
dans cette station déjà noire de monde
dix mille skieurs se sont croisés sur
les pistes aujourd'hui le vendée globe
est le premier à bandol abandon le
français hervé laurent a été victime
d'une avarie pour lui c'est terminé la
déception bien sûr c'est la deuxième
fois qu'il participait à cette course
autour du monde à la voile sans escale
et sans assistance les concurrents sont
au large de l'afrique du sud non loin du
cap manuel tissier
mer agitée bateau blessés dans la
tempête des mers du sud
hervé laurent a cassé un safran une
pièce essentielle de son monocoque la
rage au coeur
il doit renoncer l'aventuré est finie et
par rapport à tous les gens qui se sont
investis dans sept projets cette
aventure-là s'intéresseront c'est
vraiment une horreur
et voilà ça se termine là avec là avec
une petite pièce qui cassent et voilà
c'est rendre le navigateur breton
devrait atteindre l'afrique du sud après
demain pour réparer et peut-être
repartir hors course pendant ce temps
jean le cam et vincent riou mène
toujours la flotte poursuivi par roland
jourdain à bord de son bateau
jourdain a filmé les derniers oiseaux au
large du continent africain dans
quelques jours les dix neuf rescapés
n'auront plus ce genre de spectacle il
file vers les glaces de l'antarctique
la coupe davis c'est carlos moya qui
apporte la victoire à l'espagne il a
battu l'américain andy roddick en trois
sets 6-2 7-6 7-6 à séville devant plus
de 25000 spectateurs qui ont célébré
cette deuxième coupe davis coffre carlos
moya à son pays football avec une
embellie pour l'om qui a battu caen 3 2
hier soir lors de la 17e journée de l1
une victoire pour le plus grand plaisir
de philippe troussier le nouvel
entraîneur ça rendez vous au stade
vélodrome face à auxerre samedi prochain
nouveau record battu pour le téléthon
plus de 98 millions d'euros grâce à
votre générosité des promesses de dents
qui dépasse les sommes recueillies l'an
dernier un record qui peut s'améliorer
puisque vous pouvez composer le 36 37
jusqu'à vendredi prochain retour sur
cette formidable mobilisation 30 heures
de direct sur d'autres chaînes
animé par sophie davant et gérard jugnot
j'espère que là ils ont déplacé des
montagnes promet la barre des 100
millions d'euros qu'il s'était fixé
98 millions d'euros de promesses de dons
ces trois fois plus qu il y a dix huit
ans lors de la toute première édition de
rire d'émotion
alors comme chaque année ce marathon
caritatif a suscité une vaste
mobilisation populaire 22000 animations
dans toute la france rennes millions de
bénévoles des stars tous avaient répondu
présent c'est aussi ça la force du
téléthon on espère vraiment de ce
téléthon pour continuer sur ce chemin
des thérapeutiques des années de
recherche des dons qui progressent et
des témoignages qui bouleverse
comment pour les temps s'est dotée se
doter du destin ma belle qui serait pour
toi bien cruel
en octobre tu tombé en décembre tout
basculait un examen avait suffi c'est le
verdict ni au pâtis je me bats est avec
toi je gagne lausanne
jonathan edgar tous ont accepté de
quitter l'ombre pour la lumière de
témoigner histoire de ne plus être seul
face à cette maladie y ait trois rêves
alors vas-y le plus gros c'est de
pouvoir marcher je ne pourrais pas être
là ce soir je ne le ferai faire
paiements pass y avait pas il téléthon
et puis il faut réhabiliter ce mot
guérirait c'est ce qu'on est en train de
faire à condition qu'on puisse continuer
à être aidée à être supporté n'a franchi
la barre des 70 alors jusqu'au 10
décembre le 36 37 restent opérationnels
pour un dernier élan de solidarité et
surtout pour faire mentir ce conte or et
battre le record des 100 millions
espérés parfum de noël avec en alsace ce
sentier parsemé de contes et de légendes
parade élimination dans ce village du
bas rhin il suffit de suivre le chemin
la nuit tombe et christine bost ses
berges il ya d'eau
drôle de lutins ou lampions magique
à la nuit tombée ou filles jouent les
maisons ou enguirlandé se transforme
dans des corses
on y chante comme dans le temps
oui
et on y déguste les spécialités d'antan
mais c'est les petits bateaux il y en a
plus beaucoup pas recommencer les packs
de quoi l'appât du gain il n'y a pas de
mot magnifique super l'affairé avant
noël commencé mais pour ce que le passé
ne fait pas rêver
il y à toutes sortes de rencontres
inédites fait de paillettes de strass et
de personnages mythiques
m
thoiras inaugure mois de grève grâce à
la recherche d'un homme c'est à chacun
son père noël le 6e tandis que les
comédiens costumiers décorateurs de
cette saga de noël ils sont tous
bénévoles et n'ont qu'une ambition faire
partager les valeurs traditionnelles de
cette fête noël fin de l'année le rêve
le partage jouer les contes les légendes
de noël les partager avec le public
c'était notre notre point de départ
à vos calendriers il ne reste plus
qu'une vingtaine de jours à patienter
jusqu'à noël
les célébrations du bicentenaire du
sacre de napoléon en face au dôme des
invalides quelques 350 grognards fidèles
de l'empereur aux invalides qui abrite
le tombeau de napoléon c'est celle des
amateurs de dix nations défilé dans
paris en passant sous l'arc de triomphe
au carrousel construit sous le premier
empire cinéma avec a tout de suite de
benoît jacquot un film en noir et blanc
à petit prix c'était la volonté du
réalisateur
l'histoire d'une fille de bonne famille
qui tombe amoureuse d'un voyou une
histoire de patients inspiré d'une
histoire vraie marie-jo joie alexandra
renard
du noir et blanc pour les années 70
c'est pour raconter une folle histoire
d'amour
ils ont 18 et 20 ans elle la petite
fille riche lui le beau ténébreux auteur
d'un casse sanglant elle l'a suivi dans
sa cavale
chronique d'une descente aux enfers du
romanesque pur jus ou benoît jacquot a
entraîné son héroïne
isild le besco une jeune actrice touché
par la détermination de son personnage
cette façon de respecter ce qu'elles
sont ce qu'elle ressent et qu'elle y
aille ça je trouve ça très beau et ça
m'émeut oui d'autant plus qu'il s'agit
d'une histoire vraie survenue en février
trois garçons de belleville qui se
prennent pour des robins des bois braque
une banque
avenue de la république le caissier tué
l'un des braqueurs aussi prise d'otage
fuite en voiture
et c'est le début d'une cavale de plus
d'une année où les suivent deux jeunes
filles de bonne famille elisabeth fanger
était l'une d'elles inculpé pour recel
de criminel elle aura dix ans de mise à
l'épreuve et son prince a rappelé
qu'elle ne reverra plus sera battu en
1981 elle en a fait un livre benoît
jacquot une fiction
il tient à respecter la noblesse des
sentiments de l'auteur
enfin rien c'est comme un devoir pour
moi que de deux coups de ne pas la
trahir en quelque sorte pour elle en
tout cas c'était quelque chose de très
très important de l'ordre du destin de
la destinée qui lui est arrivé et que je
restitue et ça c'était comme restituer
quelque chose de grave on est vraiment
bon chemin
ce n'est pas du bonnie and clyde on est
ici dans la team au coeur du coeur d'un
joli papillon qui se brûle les ailes
avec la fougue et la conscience de la
jeunesse avec benoît jacquot le
romantisme a encore de beaux jours
devant lui
c'est la fin de ce journal je vous
remercie de votre attention à suivre la
météo patrice drevet
20h55 votre film harry un ami qui vous
veut du bien le dernier journal à 00h30
avec jean claude renaud trésor
christophe hondelatte 20h david pujadas
demain soir vous croisez présentée par
arlette chabot qui s'intéressera aux
méthodes et aux moyens de la police et
puis autre thème de débat
le racisme anti vieux excellente fin de
soirée sur rance